kiki what are you doing with your life
hey girl so good to see you again girl
you look good girl okay first of all
okay
um i love this scene where alice was
watching pam greer
for the first time what was it like to
put yourself in that character's mindset
of someone who has never seen a strong
black woman kicking everyone's butt on
screen before
i mean i just had to take it back to a
place of me of a place of wonder the
first time that i saw something that
blew my mind whether it be
first time that i'd seen someone
performing on stage or the first time
i'd seen my mom performing in church um
it's just a sense of wonder uh that i
needed to tap into in that moment and of
course you know just the reality that
you know it's kind of like the the
poetry of that is
what
coffee is being to alice is who alice is
going to be to someone else as they
watch the movie so also understanding
the elements of that was also also put
me in a sense of awe
yes yes oftentimes you know films about
black history cause black trauma but
this film is different how do you hope
this film empowers the youth that watch
it
oh my gosh the youth is the very thing
for me you know that i'm thinking about
with this movie and why i felt it was so
important because it takes us back to
history and it of course exists in the
slave narrative but it's not told in a
way that is disempowering and it's not
told with using trauma porn so i really
love for the generation to be able to a
take a look at this this new information
in history and be inspired maybe to tell
more stories that allow us to unpack our
history but they don't have to always
exist in this way that triggers us um in
unhealthy sense you know we can you can
give edutainment we can educate and be
entertaining at the same time yeah we
can use our history as a source of
empowerment and resilience you know when
you see alice discover that she's
a slave you know that she's been a slave
and she's reading about civil rights
movement and all these things that she
missed and she was not a part of the
idea would be that oh now she's gonna
pity herself but actually she did she
felt such an overwhelming sense of
gratitude and she felt that man i have
now even a greater chance you know at
tomorrow and the day after that and day
after day it like it it filled her with
so much spirit and i think
seeing that moment in itself to me is so
important for the youth to know that the
pain that you've endured it doesn't have
to be a source of shame for you it
actually can be used as a source of
resilience
i love that
is no about aliens or gnaw
very good question um you guys are
definitely gonna have to wait to see i
wish i could tell you four okay but does
nope stand for not of planet earth like
i am
i've seen that and i thought that was
really cool but nope really is just like
what black folks say like no
i mean at least in my opinion i never
like me and jordan go back and forth
with the theories online and so i gotta
text him and ask him like yo like is
nope randomly an acronym you know what i
mean he might say yeah he might say nope
what you don't even know
come on kiki okay girl bye
no
bye sis love you have a good one